vendeur de thermopompes astrologues
pour josé riopel la patience a ses
limites ce qui me fâche c'est que j'ai
beau leur dire il ya une loi vous devez
la respecter la liste nationale de
numéros de télécommunication exclus est
entrée en vigueur en 2008 beaucoup
d'inscriptions plus de 13 millions de
numéros et beaucoup d'insatisfaction
surtout que les importuns ils sont
difficiles à identifier
j'ai dû les faire venir je collectionne
les cartes d'affaires et finalement il
m'a dit ben moi j'ai pas le temps de
regarder si le numéro est sur la liste
exclu j'ai d'autres choses à faire
il y a les appels indésirables
d'entrepreneurs légitime mais il ya de
plus en plus d'athlètes d'arnaqueurs de
partout dans le monde qui donne du fil à
retordre au crtc
on reçoit beaucoup de plaintes mais on
dénote le pata de 40 à 45% sont reliés à
des arnal les arnaqueurs ont accès à des
robots et à des logiciels bon marché qui
leur permet d'inonder les réseaux de
milliers d'appels ils perdent leurs
victimes grâce à la mystification
communément appelée spoofing se bouffer
c'est le fait d'envoyer un faux mur au
téléphone lorsqu'on fait un appel
téléphonique de quelqu'un ça permet de
se faire passer pour quelqu'un d'autre
le crtc a reçu plus de 2 millions de
plaintes mais seulement 167 amendes ont
été imposées
beaucoup de gens des experts disent vous
manquer de personnel pas idéalement
c'est sûr que si j'avais encore plus de
personnes à ma disposition
on sera encore plus efficace l'organisme
reçoit en moyenne 95 mille plaintes par
année et pour gérer tout ça une
quinzaine d'enquêteurs au canada pour
cet expert
c'est trop peu une manière de mieux
appliquer la loi est d'augmenter les
ressources
l'application plus stricte de la loi
passe par un financement accru de la
part du gouvernement
depuis le lancement de la liste le crt
s'est tout de même imposé des amendes
totalisant 9,2 millions de dollars quant
à josé riopel ces démarches ont permis
de faire condamner une entreprise à 3000
$ d'amandes en 2010 et elle compte bien
récidiver oui à locatives ont rappelé je
vais enregistrer à nouveau l'appel et
cathy vont venir on va filmer en ce qui
concerne les arnaqueurs qui utilise des
robots et des logiciels
le crtc a exigé que les compagnies de
téléphone mettent en place des systèmes
pour bloquer et retracer les appels qui
sont manifestement et désirable du si la
fin de l'année ici un cerf normand radio
canada montréal